but the dream also turns into a
nightmare you hear that the dream also
turns into a nightmare I used to think
that a cross was protecting two people
there's no super sit like a good luck
yeah if you look at the music industry
all around the world even rock pop
whatever it is when a beat behind the
opponent man it's funny because Napoleon
Mucha actually tried to talk to me about
Islam a few times and I I rejected it
like a lot of people and I remind myself
to this day and I see all these names in
the Quran Jesus Moses I'm familiar with
these don't having a big cross on my
chest even when I was Christian people
what I said a Christian should we don't
listen and try to understand the Quran
if you really Christian you believe that
you will believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
please please be with you you you
reminded me of you guys remember our
brother Napoleon who was with the
outlaws now you remember Tupac Shakur
you remember him yeah I remember you
most do you do you're still listening to
his song you shouldn't be while you're
doing that man come on now got a rise to
the next level and you did you rose
above all that yes sir and you actually
you know brother Napoleon right that's
my big bro now let's let the cat out the
bag how are you connected to Tupac
so you got to park you got ammo Napoleon
the outlaws are you fitting all this I
was about 15 16 years old I first met
Tupac Shakur you kind of doesn't kind of
looks like to park you know you know I'm
not living that lifestyle anymore but
I'm struggling still with certain things
you know the struggle was beauty because
we struggle comes patience sacrifice
this is how you get to gender to
struggle yeah anything easy try to stay
away from so you were so now around 15
years old okay 15 I meant do big psych
him anew I was able to meet to pot so at
15 years old
you're meeting to park and this was like
the Mike we can say Tupac was or is
considered like like Elvis Presley was
the king of rock and roll Michael
Jackson was the king of pop music and
Tupac was I mean can you safely say he's
the king of rap music hip-hop so you're
meeting now the what would people would
consider a legend in the hip-hop lives
and I was nervous I never told Tupac
half-truth photo bottom it was more
act like I was used to the situation how
did the circumstances happen that you're
actually getting to meet him okay my
father my girlfriend's son name is Manu
but big syke was the news friend site
rapid ICA's uh when the two pucks very
close close partners and robbed the
friends day because they ordered me of
course yeah
to park is like seven years older than
me so once I heard that too part was
messin with big cyclamen knew I knew
that because I can get myself around a
situation being close diam to them
psyche Manu and next thing you know just
like this I said man I wonder when I
seen a dish I'm like man I want to get
on that you know my house I see so this
is back in now Julia before Islam you're
saying now
this is how I looked at Tupac that's a
look how can i how can i hook up with
this guy okay who girls like laughing
said I look like yeah it's back then
when I was coming up dark-skinned wasn't
really too popular yeah it was the
light-skinned guys you know okay so girl
is a couple girls and guys and saying
like too far yeah
so next thing you know I seen him on TV
and I kind of like Lea them and then
when I found out that psychons and Newt
was around them I said hi canva knew who
are they these are guys hi met two
parties are there rappers also yeah new
wasn't a rapper it was a street guy but
psych which was my new friend he rapped
do people know who because no he passed
away two years ago he was part of the
how laws and they look like two so
that's how I met Tupac - nice - yeah and
I'm 15 years old I saw miss she made
Napoleon do that cause all younger than
Tupac in Psych things the older God yeah
it was no young pup strong hang around
okay so what happens to fast forward now
so so that's when you met him and now
how did you end up in a group that know
the outlaws is like was that a subgroup
now that's that's like you know you have
the famous rapper and then they start
they want to make more money yeah so now
they get groups out of them right so
they can make and manufacture more
records get more because all about the
Benjamins who's singing that all about
the Benjamins that big innit that's Puff
Daddy and Puff Daddy we don't want to
mention puff day because they were the
opposites right there at the East Coast
West Coast yeah but you know we passed
it okay he's still around
daddy Puff Daddy yeah
may the Creator guide all of them yes so
now okay so now what happens so now how
do you how do you end up in this group
with Napoleon my brother Napoleon how
you doing I miss that brother me was
amazing brother yes so now Napoleon do
you still stay in touch with him of
course yeah we talk I follow my
Instagram I've been to Saudi Arabia
masha'Allah when I went to Dubai he
picked me up from the airport
that's our brother we've had him on the
program a few times seen him he was on I
asked him I said man I gotta get a
Toronto in there so that's what your
name was
hy hates rotten H Rother up so we got H
Rotter from the Tupac crew from The
Outlaw so how did you end up now in the
outlaws okay so which actually sold how
many like sixty was a sixty million
records how many sub under Tupac at a
Tupac died a lot of things changed
obviously because he was the main head
of the body
yeah wants to pop you know we lost
pocket was everything into change but to
parkings to actually actually been a rap
when i was 15 16 years old I was nervous
I didn't I didn't come out of my shell
until Tupac died and then the outlaws
there was already a group but they
grabbed me put me on their first album
they put
things like I said when Tupac passed
away things was just very we're all
young we are under 21 yeah and we were
supposed to be the little homies me and
Napoleon's little brother main meal and
they were supposed to be like the big
guys the big brothers down but there was
only a year two older than less and I
feel like we was all immature at that
time so I mean that's the dream a young
youth now that's what who they're
looking at they're looking at these hip
star the hip hop stars that's what they
want to be like right that's what they
want to emulate copy so now for you guys
to be actually around people like that
that's like the dream isn't it yes sir
it was but the dream also turns into a
nightmare you hear that the dream also
turns into a nightmare yes
and this is well if you look at the
music industry all around the world even
rock pop whatever it is when a beat
behind their poetry is how vile if y'all
like to love words so much do poetry
without a beat and this allowed if you
stay away from the beat it controls
people it makes people move and do all
this stuff and this what makes the music
come on yeah so what happens now so how
do you end up in this group and how did
you get from living that lifestyle to
actually now living the lifestyle that
actually is if any African American goes
to his roots even he watched the movie
roots and he looks at Kunta Kinte he's
calling upon the crater Allah Malcolm X
Muhammad Ali so anyone who went back to
their roots and there's a deep history
with the african-american people and
there originates in Islam so how did you
coming back to the natural way to it's
not man it's funny because Napoleon
boots are actually tried to talk to me
about Islam a few times and I I rejected
it like a lot of people and I remind
myself to this day that when I tried
when we gave Dawa we have to be patient
and we got especially people who not
born in this religion a lot of people
are born into Islam so it was easier for
them to listen in the SEP 17 2014 2 a
lot of people
and I became Muslim I didn't go to
prison I didn't get shot up you know I
mean I was healthy on our tiptoes and
doing a lot of things and somehow I'm
not gonna say somehow I lost upon the
Huaorani chose me and I seen a sign with
my eyes literally I'm gonna tell you
exactly when I saw a crescent moon with
the star like a perfect like the things
that you see on the flag I seen that in
real life doing Ramadan which was 19 I'm
sorry 2004 my birthday is November 30th
and it was towards the end of Ramadan I
wasn't Muslim yet I know understanding
of Islam but I knew about obviously not
seen this crescent moon before Emma
story that's next to it so on my
birthday I actually seen his son and I
had a choice since I was out partying
that night and I had a choice someone
called me
long story short when I wasn't seeing
when I saw 10 hours later it still
wasn't good enough for me to understand
what that fully meant I knew that was
something special but I I'm not gonna
say that that's what the last part of
our Allah is truly God because that one
situation didn't really convince me
because once I woke up I was ready to
get back to the doing it even though I
saw the star in the crescent moon right
but a lot of Noah's his slave so I went
to Walmart my mother and family came
into town that day because it was my
birthday and my mother you know offered
to clean my house not like you know I
like that before birthday she said I was
bachelor at the time living by myself
and she said I want to clean your house
for your birthday so I got a [ __ ]
cleaner and two men approached me and he
actually could we talk to you for a
minute and I said yes sir what's going
on
I said we've been alerted that you have
a restraining order against you from one
of our employees in the store you're not
supposed to be such a such feet from
them so I said wait a minute I'm
restraining me the person knows about it
correct so I never knew I had a
restraining order in my life so I tell
the two gentlemen that approached me
that this is a mistake and I don't have
a restraining order and showed me the
individual and Santa I have a
restraining order against me they took
me to this woman she looked me dead in
my face and said yes that's him so I'm
like wait a minute
this is a remind you I seen when I seen
about ten hours ago so I go on the back
they find out it's not me they run my
name's and okay we're sorry we made a
mistake but you got a tracking traffic
ticket and we called Metro you have to
go to jail so I'm like wait I just told
you this wasn't me you made a mistaken
identity
this is my birthday I showed you today
it's November 30 if I see my ID says
November 30th and he still took it was
taking me to jail so I was a little
frustrated I get to jail it wasn't
prison because I don't want people think
all he went to prison became you notice
I'm happening but I went God sent me to
jail for about ten hours out of those
ten hours as I'm telling you know
everyone goes to jail and they're
innocent I don't know if you've been in
jail hopefully not but when people go to
jail you actually what you in there for
like man I ain't do nothing this is
everyone's story right yeah but I really
didn't do nothing
you know I'm saying so long story short
they as I'm in jail and I'm telling my
story to a person all of a sudden I get
division of the star in the Crescent so
I stopped I had to quit telling the
story and our partner to say
all of a sudden I seen this miraculous
sign and all of a sudden I'm in jail for
something I couldn't even control me
getting here I knew I put someone two
together and said this is from God even
though I wasn't Muslim I knew this was
some spiritual situation so my god Jail
which is only 10 hours but bailed out
and a person that picked me up I told
him to take me to the library
immediately I didn't want to go eat food
I didn't want to go
nothing just take me to the library some
deep in my heart right now go to the
library and go to the Middle Eastern
section pick up some literature the
Quran for example I think was first and
I see all these names in the Quran Jesus
Moses I'm familiar with these don't
having a big cross on my chest even I
was Christian I was not the angel but I
love God so you were like most most
people and and this is not to cause
offence to any of our Christian friends
out there anybody in humanity but you
see many of the rappers and many of
people doing opposite to the teachings
of Jesus and the prophets and God but
they wear you know certain emblems right
the Ray the Cross the Morningstar all
those things and out of ignorance they
end up doing things so you were wearing
a cross thinking cuz you told just like
50 and on your boy 50 years you ever met
50 cent no but who had the cross and
know there's a lot of ignorance still
have the cross and becomes more like a
good luck charm or something right so
then what our story short that I used to
think that a cross was protecting to
like people yes I was super sit like a
good luck he's gonna protect you so
don't know when I can protect you is the
one who created you yes but I brought
that up to say let me say this to for
the record I don't want people you know
shut out the Christianity and I always
because Allah says in the Quran
a true Christian when he hears the words
of his Lord he would know that this
Quran is from his maker yes you know I'm
saying so people that said any
Christians should we don't listen and
try to understand the Quran if you're
really Christian and you believe that
you will believe in
in the Quran and this fix the little
difficulties that you are struggling
with with Christianity
this is why people don't go to church
things of this nature good doctrine has
been tampered the Trinity and all the
theology so people actually believe in
God
yes but they just don't believe in the
doctrine so you find them not be
struggling to go to church you were
struggling with that also of course I
mean God was a one point point point too
too many people that struggle with the
same issues yeah but Islam now I go to
the Masjid every day yeah way in
Christianity you go once a week and you
still don't go yeah you offered to come
just once a week you still can't come
concert we rapping singing songs
everything is still unsure just
entertainment if they show me how God
Jesus or Moses or any of the prophets
may God peace and blessing be upon them
they show me any time that they worship
God in this manner then I will come to
just so like most of the rappers and
people in general they believe in God
but there is no structure there's no
blueprint and then you're confused over
here with the theology and nothing is
straightforward cut and clear so you
start making up your own thing as you
got that powerful doing like this and
then you got the material world so what
happens now you're wearing the cross and
then what happens so I read the
miniature because yes see Jesus Moses
Noah Adam all these names I'm on the
Caribe the Word of God
I'm already familiar with these words
because that's why I say I don't want to
talk bad about Christianity because if
it wasn't for Christianity I wouldn't
understood who those names work yeah so
we're not putting down anybody now put
me down but you have to grow I've got a
goal from white belt to Bluebell from
what from GED to high school to college
in Islam we're still growing
yesterday we leaders of the Prophet
Muhammad son-in-law a he was sometimes
said this Deen is like sipping from the
ocean so we have to be aware and
understanding how much knowledge you get
humble yourself and not only that you
can tell the knowledge you have by the
people that you have given Shahada this
how I like to look at it because if you
have all this knowledge then you will be
given sadhus you'll be helping and
teaching people this Deen is not about
learning this long sit in the corner
rocking back and forth and thinking one
heaven this is not what this is about
so now what happens now so you're
learning about the clear message of pure
monotheism connecting it with all the
messengers of God there in the Koran
it's really anybody who looks at a
sincerely generally it's so captivating
believable message bhoot proof evidence
beyond what any reasonable person needs
so what happens next
about two months later I end up saying
that is but I'll study first like I said
I went you study there's nothing worthy
of worship except the creator of the
heavens and earth and Muhammad is the
messenger just like Jesus Abraham Moses
before him they all brought the same
message worship the One God what happens
next so you say the Shahada I said
Shahada become Muslim and 14 years later
Here I am I'm still struggling a lot of
things but the difference is I lost
first of all I lost upon I don't want
these youngsters to get discouraged yes
you're gonna mess up you still messing
up I understand I am too so we don't
want to feed these junctions they'd have
to be perfect to be Muslim you know
you're gonna make some mistakes of loss
upon I want to Allah said if you didn't
make mistakes I will wipe you out and
create the people who did call upon me
for the sake of my mercy that they
messed up this is not purpose we're not
angels angelic form creatures we are
human beings and the Prophet I mean a
loss of fun I want to Allah says that
humans are made from clay and we have
intellect and desires the angels are
made from light they have intellect with
no desires the animals they have this
desires with no intimate
now if the human being was to put his
intellect over his desires will be
locked up with the Malaika with the
angels on a day
qiyamah if the human being puts his
desires over his internic will be life
though with the animals on the day so
what advice now you accept Islam it's a
struggle life is a jihad it's a struggle
struggle to stay upright to be doing
what the Creator wants you to do but
he's the most loving most merciful make
a mistake you turned back GPS is set on
Jenna so you do your best to give us
human being possible that you can be
living by God Almighty's guidance not by
your desires you fall short but you keep
turning back to God so what advice now
do you have the message because you live
that life of the rap industry of having
the instead of the around you know the
call to prayer shakedowns at them write
music you know the industry you know
that life all you know the glitz and
glamour Fame and money you know you know
everything that the bling-bling just
standing middle my best advice you're
gonna you're gonna have some desires
that overwhelm you which is cool Allah
gave you that right but just taste it
don't get wrapped in it it's one thing
to taste something you know but don't
get full to the point where you've
gained and weight from it you know I'm
saying this is how life is we all wanna
curiosity is what makes a human being
it's okay we forgetful people we've made
to forget but I don't want you guys to
think that just because you listening
some music and you got the shaitaan give
you an excuse to not to pray because
once you praying is the main thing if
you hold on to your prayer you can be
you what about people to get people now
you know some of the rappers out there
to 50 Cent's you know some people who
never looked into Islam why should they
look into it's not because if they see
is tricky because even if oh like I say
as the saying goes if I lost upon Allah
to Allah God you know more Kentucky from
mr. path if Allah doesn't guide you no
matter how many times we tell them it's
not going to happen
it's actually what's in the heart so
these a lot of people want this worthy
life a loss upon Allah - Allah is so
merciful he give these people with their
heart one they heart wants to worry life
and that's what they get him so
sometimes we look at these people and
say man what God do they serve I want to
50 cent guy he got a private jet all the
stuff but we have to remember what the
Prophet Muhammad son-in-law he was
selling saying those who struggle Allah
loves morning I'm not saying you can't
have money but the money Allah knows
this better than we know ourselves some
of us if we have money we won't not only
will we not pray our hearts will become
part of this table and Allah doesn't
want that for us so he keeps the money
from this we want it so bad no Allah I'm
different I'm a hamlet and okay he gave
it to us again you know it's a what I
often leave people with is the homework
to understand that just like Diggy he
was at the top of his game but he's gone
she's at the time he was at the top he
had the money and fame on everything but
he died we're gonna die Tupac same thing
at the top and he's dead so think about
death and I leave people with this
homework and you did it and anyone that
I talked to an interviewed most people
like you did I'm sure at one point now
you asked the crater alone to guide you
very simple homework as the one who
created this universe everything in it
the one who created Tupac the one who
created biggie the one who created the
Sun the moon and Jesus asked who Jesus
asked the one God guides you why am I
here what's my purpose guide me to the
way of life you want me to be a pond
that's simple huh yes did you do that
yes I did and I'm still doing it and my
mother my biggest shot I give was my
mother wideness my mother become Muslim
she should tell me she was covered by
the butter Jesus she said tell me I was
on the wrong path we used to argue about
it I said you know what cuz I stir
because me and my mother had a difficult
relationship for the sake of Allah
Subhan Allah Allah when I read the verse
that I'm in debt to the woman that
bought me I had to change that
relationship I had to fix it and I had
to try to not do as I feel you know I'm
saying so that alone was the guidance
and these are the things I mean Islam is
a way of life we teach you how to use
the restroom how to write this up would
it eat everything we all need this we
are creating we are creation so we need
an instruction manual to operate this
creation beautiful so you have another
example we've interviewed many who lived
that lifestyle they're running away from
it to come to the Dean to come to this
way of life from the Creator why are you
running towards what they're running
away from so we left you a few things
remember the reality of death it's
coming the second is ask the Creator for
guidance alone and look at the verbatim
Word of God the Quran look at the
evidence upon evidence the signs and
signs that are there I want to thank you
so much I mean for being with us in the
lake we started with peace we end with
peace peace be upon you this is the
greeting of Jesus Moses and all the
messages of God and we said one thing
about this brother right here man may
Allah bless him and his family on me
because he's doing you know this is a
first of all the idea is beyond like
this this is the thought of having a
show that speaks on a Dean and people
struggles in everyday lives and trying
to you know have people looking up to so
many people that have nothing that
benefits us we look for these people
like I say to have money that's it they
go on to the grave they don't take the
money with them this money is the root
of distractions this money makes you
forget yourself the poor we enter Heaven
several hundred years before the rich so
why do we want money that's my question
I struggle with this theme so I want
money
and I'm like why why don't one way I
don't feed the people
am I gonna build mash it's myself
and she laughs a lot does give me this
money I treat it right so when I'm in my
grave it would benefit me and I go off
that no but I was sent about this
brother may Allah bless him and he's a
beautiful brother I'm touching a lot of
people's lives not by not because he's
getting paid to do it like everyone else
in this life everything they do is about
money
this guy's doing this for this he's
taking his time out and he's doing
things for the sake of Allah Allah Allah
Allah bless him that God has for me I
mean and thank you hope this has been a
benefit continue to tune in here to the
deed show we'll see you next time God
willing in sha allah don't forget to do
the homework